bien Madame la Ministre d'abord présente
mes excuses de vous avoir fait patienter
comme ça pendant un quart d'heure mais
évidemment nous avions de nombreuses
questions à poser au ministre de
l'Intérieur sur la préparation des
grands événements sportifs à venir nous
avons la plaisir de vous accueillir en
cette fin d'après-midi pour la
traditionnelle audition budgétaire de
l'automne
madame la ministre vautreté a
certainement été très chargé tant les
défis que traverse le monde de la
culture sont nombreux comme vous le
savez notre commission a toujours su
noué des relations de travail
particulièrement productives avec vos
prédécesseurs et vos premiers pas en
juin me paraissent s'inscrire dans cette
atmosphère confiante mais respectueuse
de nos singularités et de nos rôles
respectifs je le redis donc vous nous
trouverez toujours à vos côtés pour
avancer sur les sujets qui nous tiennent
à cœur et ils sont nombreux vous pouvez
aussi compter sur nous pour vous alerter
sur certaines problématiques comme le
montrer je crois les travaux de contrôle
réalisés par nos rapporteur au cours des
mois écoulés revenons-en aux multiples
défis du monde de la culture et aux
politiques engagées par votre ministère
pour y répondre
l'irrigation territoriale constitue l'un
des axes forts de votre budget que ce
soit en matière de patrimoine ou de
création le rapport de nos collègues
Anne Ventalon et Pierre ouzouillas sur
le patrimoine religieux a mis en
évidence les besoins importants des
collectivités pour entretenir et
restaurer ce patrimoine au-delà d'aide
financière elles attendent également de
l'État un accompagnement technique vous
nous direz dans quelle mesure le budget
pour 2023 permet éventuellement de
répondre à ses attentes nous avons noté
avec satisfaction la création d'un fond
d'innovation territoriale très largement
inspiré des propositions de Sonia de la
pauvreté et de Sylvie Robert dans le
cadre de leur rapport sur le plan de
relance en matière de création elles
appelaient de leurs vœux des outils
offrant plus de place à la
co-construction avec les collectivités
territoriales peut-être pourrez-vous
nous en dire un peu plus sur le type et
le nombre d'actions que se font à
vocation à financer et pour quel montant
que ce soit en matière de création ou
d'industrie culturelle dans ce sens
large le soutien de l'État a permis à
tous les secteurs d'être préservés
durant la crise pandémique une faut
saluer ici l'engagement des pouvoirs
publics qui très rapidement mobilisé des
moyens conséquents pour défendre la
création indemniser les cinémas soutenir
la musique et préserver la presse je le
dis d'autant plus que ce choix n'a pas
été celui de tous les pays certains
ayant littéralement laissé couler leur
secteur créatif vous avez en particulier
mis en avant la reconquête de notre
souveraineté culturelle avec un milliard
d'euros prévu pour les industries
culturelles et créatives d'ici 2030
suivant des modalités que vous pourrez
peut-être également nous préciser je
salue bien entendu ces ambitions mais je
ne répondent pas entièrement aux
inquiétudes du moment je parle bien
entendu des conséquences du choc
d'inflation actuel qui plonge les
acteurs dans un désarroi assez proche de
celui qui était le leur pendant la crise
pandémique à titre d'exemple le rapport
de Michel logier sur la presse
quotidienne régionale
publié en juillet dernier l'excellent
rapport oui à démontré l'impact sur
toute la filière de la hausse des prix
du papier aujourd'hui évalué à plus de
200 millions après 200 millions d'euros
à la charge d'un secteur en crise depuis
une dizaine d'années je n'oublie pas les
établissements publics comme la
Bibliothèque nationale de France où
l'AFP qui vont devoir composer avec ce
contexte inflationniste ce qui pesera
certainement sur leur capacité à
investir je pense aussi à toutes nos
toutes notre réseau d'écoles école
d'architecture école d'art conservatoire
qui sont parfois en graves difficultés
pour boucler leur budget je veux
également enfin mentionner le Centre
national de la musique auquel nous avons
consacré une très riche table ronde la
semaine dernière vous avez choisi de
confier une mission au sénateur Julien
barjetton ce qui est une reconnaissance
de son travail bien entendu mais du
travail de l'ensemble de la Commission
sur ce sujet pour autant des
interrogations ont été émises sur la
capacité du CNM assuré ses missions en
2023 avec des moyens qui sont rede si je
peux le dire ainsi modeste en un mot nos
industries culturelles ont été
préservées pendant la crise il serait
dommage qu'elle soit mis en difficulté
faute de soutien aujourd'hui s'agissant
de l'audiovisuel public la réforme de la
gouvernance et de ses entreprises
figuraient au programme du travail de
vos prédécesseurs un projet de loi
largement inspiré des travaux de notre
commission a été abandonnée en cours de
route faute de réforme de la gouvernance
les mutualisations entre les différentes
entreprises sont restées embryonnaires
tandis que la réduction des coûts qui
aurait été permise par un regroupement
se fait toujours attendre un rapport
rédigé au printemps par notre collègue
Jean Raymond Hugonnet et notre collègue
de la commission des finances Roger
karucci a réaffirmé la nécessité de
reprendre ce processus de rapprochement
qui dans notre esprit est inséparable de
la question de la redéfinition des
missions et des moyens il n'est pas
étonnant dans ces conditions que
l'absence d'avancer sur la gouvernance
s'accompagne de mesure transitoires sur
le financement le projet de loi de
finances prévoit une hausse plus de 3%
des crédits à 3,8 milliards d'euros
cette hausse des crédits est inégalement
répartie puisqu'elle bénéficie
essentiellement Radio France et France
médiumonde j'observe que cette hausse
des crédits est relative puisqu'elle
vise aussi à compenser les effets de la
suppression de la cape en juillet
dernier qui a eu pour conséquence de
soumettre ces entreprises à la taxe sur
les salaires conséquences qui n'avaient
pas été énoncé lors du débat sur le du
PLF nous examinons nous examinerons
parlons prochainement les avenants aux
comes des différentes entreprises qui
ont pour objet de préciser la feuille de
route telle qu'elle définit par
l'actionnaire le choix de prolonger les
comme d'un an sans définir une véritable
vision de long terme comme les
incertitudes qui entourent l'avenir du
financement de l'audiovisuel public
après 2024 crée un contexte particulier
qui évidemment nous interpelle alors que
la com doit renouveler les mandats des
présidentes de Radio France et de France
médiumonde au début de l'année prochaine
sur la base des projets des candidats
forcés de constater qu'une le plus ces
projets ne pourront pas prendre en
compte la trajectoire financière des
entreprises pour les années à venir ni
les priorités définies par l'État pour
le reste du quinquennat nous avons un
maintes fois regretté cette gouvernance
déficience de l'audiovisuel public dont
vous n'êtes pas responsable madame la
ministre c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous vous réitérons notre disponibilité
pour aller apporter des réponses qui
devront être d'autant plus ambitieuses
que les temps pour les adopter aura été
conséquentes madame la ministre je vais
donc vous donner la parole pour un
propos préliminaire et puis ensuite
l'ensemble de nos rapporteurs et
l'ensemble des sénateurs essénatrices
qui le souhaiteront vous
interrogeons sur l'ensemble des
crédits budgétaires dont vous avez la
maîtrise
merci merci beaucoup chers président
Laurent Lafont
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
suis ravie d'être parmi vous ce soir
pour parler de ce budget de la culture
et des médias un budget historique en
hausse au total de 7 %
4,2 milliards pour la partie culture et
3,8 milliards pour l'audiovisuel public
nous y reviendrons
à cela s'ajoute les taxes les ressources
affectées pour le financement du cinéma
de la musique du théâtre privé c'est à
peu près 770 millions d'euros à avoir en
tête
n'oublions pas aussi les crédits
d'impôts multiples qui font un total de
2 milliards d'euros de soutien à
l'ensemble de l'écosystème de la culture
n'oublions pas aussi le loto du
patrimoine qui permet d'injecter en
complément de notre budget 20 millions
d'euros par an environ pour soutenir des
sites en partie protégés en partie non
classées nos inscrits un peu partout sur
le territoire ce qui fait un total au
fond de 11 milliards d'euros dans le
périmètre du ministère de la Culture en
2023 soit 527 millions de plus qu'en
ce budget
est un budget qui nous permet de faire
face au défi du présent et de préparer
l'avenir
il
reflète un certain nombre de priorités
pour beaucoup d'entre elles inspirées je
pense comme vous l'avez dit de vos
travaux et de nos échanges et en tout
cas un budget qui
même si ça se voit pas toujours dans
toutes les cases de toutes les lignes et
un budget d'irrigation territoriale à
tous les niveaux quand on parle
patrimoine quand on parle création quand
on parle lecture publique quand on parle
soutien aux entreprises culturelles
soutien aux radios par exemple
l'associatif elles sont partout sur le
territoire donc j'insiste vraiment là
dessus sur ce déploiement territorial de
notre action et donc du budget
c'est un budget qui prend à bras le
corps l'enjeu de la transition
écologique et le défi de très court
terme là du choc pour une partie des
lieux culturels de la hausse des coûts
de l'énergie pour les établissements les
plus fragiles les plus impactés ceux qui
sont de réels passoire thermique
malheureusement il n'en reste beaucoup
donc ce budget permet d'avoir une
enveloppe d'à peu près 56 millions
d'euros pour venir en soutien à ces
établissements
impactés par la hausse des coûts de
l'énergie mais ce qui m'intéresse
surtout c'est d'insister à plus long
terme sur les investissements que nous
déployons pour accompagner les acteurs
culturels dans leur transition
écologique notre budget d'investissement
est à 663 millions d'euros en 2023 avec
66 millions de hausse un budget en
augmentation qui va permettre en
priorité de fléchir des travaux de
rénovation d'isolation thermique de
d'amélioration des performances
énergétiques on pourra y revenir et il y
a également un budget supplémentaire au
Centre national de la musique de 900 000
euros dédiés spécifiquement à la
transition écologique de la filière
musicale
c'est un budget qui protège et qui
valorise le patrimoine budget historique
là aussi 1,1 milliard d'euros consacré
au patrimoine c'est une hausse de 87
millions qui permet de maintenir une
dynamique qui avait été très forte grâce
au plan de relance 87 millions de
hausses qui se répartissent pour les
cathédrales leur sécurisation pour le
fond incitatif pour le patrimoine avec
les régions pour l'archéologie et les
fouilles programmées pour une série de
rénovations prioritaires je ne peux pas
tout vous les lister mais par exemple
l'abbaye de Clairvaux la Cité de
Carcassonne les tours de La Rochelle etc
c'est un budget qui amplifie notre
politique d'éducation artistique
à l'école comme pour les jeunes via le
Pass Culture à partir de 18 ans mais
avec un passe culture maintenant qui se
déploie au collège dès la 4e une partie
du budget est d'ailleurs pas visible sur
le budget ministère de la Culture
puisqu'il a l'éducation nationale mais
vous verrez que sur cet enjeu de
l'éducation artistique nous sommes à
plus 24 millions d'euros avec un focus
que j'ai tenu à
faire sur la lecture le soutien aux
bibliothèques le soutien aux livres
accessible pour les personnes en
situation de handicap avec la création
d'une plateforme dédiée à cela le
soutien en librairie A des
manifestations littéraires à la
distribution aussi des livres parce
qu'il y a des difficultés d'acheminement
notamment d'outre-mer
donc un budget renforcé aussi pour la
lecture c'est un budget qui tient ses
promesses pour garantir le pluralisme
des médias et l'accès à une information
fiable libre indépendante je l'avais dit
devant vous je l'avais dit dans
l'émission cette suppression de la
redevance ne signifiait pas suppression
du budget de l'audiovisuel public loin
de là nous avons compensé comme nous
l'avions dit à l'euro près les effets
fiscaux nous avons aussi intégré une
grande part de l'inflation telle qu'elle
est estimée pour 2023 par la Banque de
France et ça fait un total de plus 114,4
millions d'euros de budget à le diesel
public pour atteindre 3,8 milliards
et un budget supplémentaire pour la
presse une des réformes prioritaires sur
laquelle nous avons travaillé avec la
filière c'est la réforme de la
distribution
après le rapport gianesini pour aller
vers plus de portage et moins de
postages cette réforme qui a besoin
d'être accompagnée à hauteur de 17
millions d'euros et une augmentation
aussi notre fonds de soutien à
l'expression radiophonique locale de
d'environ 2 millions d'euros pour
soutenir toutes les radios qui
œuvrent sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est un budget qui également renforce
la création française nos métiers les
métiers d'art et qui portent la voie de
la France dans le monde numérique
dans le cadre de France 2030 il y a un
budget vous l'avez mentionné Charles
Laurent Lafond d'un milliard d'euros qui
ne s'affichent pas là dans vos tablettes
mais qui est bien prévu dans France 2030
à horizon 2030 qui va nous permettre de
porter des projets de développement
d'infrastructures de tournage de
post-production des formations pour les
futurs talents qu'ils soient créatifs ou
techniques et qui va nous permettre
aussi de déployer des nouvelles
technologies de l'immersif au service de
la culture et au service aussi du lien
entre la culture physique et numérique
mais là vous avez dans ce budget plus 48
millions pour soutenir ce que j'ai
appelé notre souveraineté culturelle
dans les mondes physiques et numériques
avec cette commande acte 2 demande de
nouveau qui va se poursuivre avec
Villers-Cotterêts qui se déploie avec un
plan dédié aux métiers d'art qui va
avoir une ambition nouvelle à partir de
ce budget c'est aussi le reflet de
compétences au sein du ministère qui
sont renforcés qui sont
celles de 29000 agents qui font vivre ce
ministère au quotidien avec plusieurs
priorités dont nous pourront revenir
puisque vous avez mentionné Charleroi
Lafont cette question aussi des moyens
humains qui sont notamment pour le
patrimoine pour l'archéologie pour les
architectes de bâtiments de France qui
sont aux côtés des collectivités tous
les jours la masse salariale du
ministère elle augmente de 38,5 millions
pour s'établir à 532 millions et nous
avons consacré 11 millions à la
poursuite du plan de rattrapage
indemnitaire notamment direction des
architectes urbanistes de l'État et des
conservateurs du patrimoine au
financement d'une prime pour les
enseignants chercheurs des écoles
nationales supérieures d'architecture et
à l'augmentation de la rémunération des
contractuels
on a aussi
poursuivi grâce à ce budget on va
pouvoir poursuivre la réforme
indemnitaire des agents de l'INRAP
l'Institut national des recherches
archéologiques préventives
et puis évidemment nous prenons en
compte la hausse des trois et demi pour
cent de la valeur du point d'indice qui
fait à peu près 14 millions dans notre
budget nous pourrons y revenir
ce focus sur les compétences il est
aussi au sein du ministère de la Culture
important de rappeler l'importance de
nos établissements d'enseignement
supérieur artistique puisque le mystère
et culture touche 37000 étudiants en
formation et ce sont eux au fond la
relève le vivier de demain qui va être
la création artistique de demain mais je
pense notamment aux architectes puisque
nous avons près de 20 000 étudiants en
école d'architecture donc nous avons mis
l'accent dans le budget 2023 sur ses
écoles où nous avions des constats assez
alarmants depuis quelques années avec
plus de bourse plus de revalorisation
pour les enseignants plus
d'investissements pour améliorer la
performance énergétique des bâtiments ce
qui est logique quand on est dans une
école d'architecture après tout donc
priorité pour l'enseignement supérieur
priorité pour l'emploi aussi soutien à
l'emploi artistique soutien aux artistes
auteurs avec plus 13 millions d'euros
mais je veux pas être beaucoup plus
longue en tout cas c'est un budget qui
nous permet de consolider la résilience
qui a été possible pour notre secteur
culturel après cette crise sanitaire
qu'il a impecté et de se projeter dans
l'avenir pour penser l'innovation la
création de demain et former la jeunesse
à être le public de demain le public qui
va faire vivre la création de demain
comme la dernière fois je vous avais lu
un poème lors de mon audition je me suis
dit qu'il fallait que je vous en trouve
un pour cette fin de journée surtout
après l'audition du ministre de
l'Intérieur
il va l'entendre non c'est un poème de
Federico Garcia Lorca
qui s'appelle chant nouveau
le soir a dit je suis altérée d'ombre la
Lune a dit moi d'étoiles brillantes la
source cristalline veut des lèvres et
des soupirs le vent mais moi j'ai soif
de parfum et de rire j'ai soif de chant
nouveau sans lune et sans iris et sans
amour défunte soif d'un champ matinal
qui troublerait les eaux dormantes de
l'avenir des eaux dormantes de l'avenir
pardon en plissant d'espérance leurs
ondes et leurs fanges donc voilà ce
champ qui va remplir l'avenir
d'espérance encore et toujours c'est la
culture je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre non ce nom pour
le poème mais aussi pour les
informations plus financières que vous
nous avez donné avant sans plus tarder
moi je vais donner la parole aux
rapports budgétaires sur la commission
de la culture mais aussi ceux de la
commission des finances je crois notre
collègue Vincent et Blais également Jean
Raymond Hugonnet va commencer ensuite
pour les crédits de l'audiovisuel Michel
Legé ensuite pour ceux de la presse
Julien barjoton pour le crédit des
industries culturels Jérémy Baki pour
ceux du cinéma
Sabine dragster pour ceux du patrimoine
Sylvie Robert pour la création et enfin
Vincent et Blais pour laotype de la
commission des finances pour le rapport
spécial culture je ne sais pas si Didier
Rambaud est revenu
il était là mais je le vois plus facile
il arrive de nouveau il aura bien sûr la
parole
Jean Raymond merci monsieur le Président
effectivement mes questions très au
compte de concours financiers avant sa
l'audiovisuel public madame la ministre
bonsoir
l'audiovisuel public voit ses crédit
augmenté de plus 3%, cette hausse est
claire mais elle ne concerne pas
l'ensemble des sociétés de la même façon
les crédits de France Télévisions sont
stables à plus 1% ceux de Radio France
et de Lina augmente modérément tandis
que ceux d'art et France et de France
mediamonde connaissent une avancée
significative de près de 10% ce qui est
à souligner quels sont les raisons qui
expliquent cette distinction opérée
entre les entreprises et comment font se
télévisions et Lina qui sont les moins
favorisés par ce budget vont-ils faire
face à la hausse de l'inflation et à la
saisie
à la taxe sur les salaires c'est ma
première question
vous avez par ailleurs choisi de
reporter la réalisation de nouveaux
comes à 2024
les avenants aux COM qui nous seront
prochainement transmis ne portant que
sur l'année 2023 or l'arcom devra
désigner des 2023 les présidents de
Radio France et de France médiamonde sur
la base du projet stratégique établi par
les différents candidats comment ces
candidats peuvent-ils construire un
projet stratégique sans connaître leur
trajectoire financière plus réelle des
entreprises qu'il dirigent comment
l'arcom peut-elle choisir des candidats
sur un projet si ce projet est en
réalité virtuelle n'est-il pas tant
enfin de réformer la gouvernance des
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public dont
on voit une nouvelle fois qu'elle n'est
pas cohérente
on va continuer je vais prendre toutes
les questions des rapporteurs Michel
logis merci monsieur le Président
bonsoir madame les ministres le
président Lafont l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure j'ai publié en juillet un
rapport complet adopté d'ailleurs à
l'unanimité de cette commission sur la
presse quotidienne régionale qui
souligne le formidable défi que
constitue le secteur pour le secteur
Laos se déplie du papier le projet de
loi de finance ne contient cependant
aucune mesure spécifique dans le même
temps les 150 millions d'euros qui de
que devaient coûter sur trois ans le
crédit d'impôt premier abonnement et sur
lequel le gouvernement avait amplement
communiqué a été plus ou moins noyé dans
les sables au point d'être supprimés
de pensez-vous pas qu'il y aurait une
justice à orienter au moins une partie
de ses fonds pour aider le secteur à
traverser cette crise de même si j'ai vu
que un abonnement avait été déposé au
sein de la commission culture de
l'assemblée et je trouve que le montant
n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux et
deuxièmement je crains beaucoup quand
même du cheminement de cet amendement
jusqu'au bout du vote de la loi dans mon
rapport je recommande également de faire
évoluer la législation sur siteo qui
engendre un coup de 22 millions d'euros
pouvez-vous me dire si la Commission
européenne
a bien été saisie ou bien s'il est
envisagé de faire sortir la filière
papier du régime très contraignant
de responsabilité l'argile du producteur
je rappelle que nous sommes le seul pays
européen avoir fait ce choix comme
chaque année le budget de loi de
finances et la triste occasion de
constater les difficultés toujours
redoutables de la distribution de la
presse je pense bien entendu à
l'opérateur France le messagerie
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il serait temps de
remettre à plat tout le système et de
rebâtir un schéma réaliste qui tiendrait
compte de l'attribution de l'attrition
inévitable de la vente papier des
quotidiens nationaux et puis puisque
vous avez commencé dans la poésie
permettez-moi de continuer et de citer
un auteur que vous aimez bien Khalil
Gibran
vous êtes bon lorsque vous marchez
fermement vers votre but ne pas
intrépide pourtant vous n'êtes pas
mauvais lorsque vous y allez en boîte en
même ceux qui boite ne vont pas en
arrière
Julien barjetton qui ne boit pas
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre alors deux questions et qui
rejoint d'ailleurs celle qui vient de
poser sur l'inflation la crise du papier
qui pèse beaucoup sur le budget des
maisons d'édition notamment les maisons
d'édition indépendante qui ne possèdent
pas de stock de papier puisque les
grandes maisons d'édition achètent du
papillon d'avance et en Destock mais
c'est pas le cas des petites comment
faire face comment aider ces petites
maisons d'édition indépendante à faire
face à la hausse des prix du papier
deuxième sujet toujours sur la librairie
les librairies indépendantes vont
retrouver à peu près les mêmes ventes
qu'avant qu'avant la crise et à peu près
la même part de marché autour de 20%
quel est le bilan que l'on peut tirer du
programme lancé par l'État sur l'aide à
la modernisation des librairies et
d'autres programmes en direction du
livre je pense aussi au programme Jeune
en librairie enfin une question au nom
de mon groupe et comme ça je n'y
reviendrai pas je ne poserai pas de
questions dans la deuxième tournée de
parole le rapport de la toujours des
comptes du 6 octobre
sur la cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris
indique que les conditions sont réunies
pour réouvrir la cathédrale Notre-Dame
avec dans les délais impartis et avec le
budget maîtrisé est-ce que vous partagez
cette optimisme cet appréciation de la
Cour des comptes dans son rapport du 6
octobre voilà pour les trois questions
de comme rapporteur et un au nom du
groupe et je m'en tiens là
Jérémy Baki pour les crédits merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
une partie de la profession a appelé le
6 octobre dernier lors d'un colloque à
Lima à des états généraux du cinéma
qu'elle accueille réservez-vous à cette
demande et comment expliquer vous la
tonalité parfois très alarmiste d'une
partie de la presse sur le cinéma
tonalité qui je le précise n'est pas
unean partagée par toute la profession
deuxième question le 4 octobre dernier
le sensei a réuni les parties prenantes
de la chronologie des médias pour un
tour de table sur la dernière version
signer le 24 janvier cette occasion il
est apparu que plusieurs acteurs dont
Disney
contestaient la chronologie et en
particulier sur l'exclusivité aux
chaînes gratuites au bout des veines de
moi ces chaînes se sont elles-mêmes
exprimées sous la forme d'une tribune
parue le 28 septembre dans le journal Le
Monde et dont je vous citerai simplement
le titre nous sommes responsables de
télévision gratuite demandons au pouvoir
public de ne pas céder au diktat des
plateformes payantes
pensez-vous qu'il est qu'il soit encore
nécessaire de revenir sur cette
chronologie et enfin une étude du Sensei
rendu publique à l'occasion du Festival
de Cannes en mai 2022 a essayé de
répondre à la question
pourquoi les Français vont-ils moins
souvent aussi au cinéma deux points
retenus mandattention le premier c'est
le prix du billet sachant qu'en réalité
il est de 7 euros en moyenne et le
deuxième point c'est le manque
d'attractivité pardon des films ce
deuxième sujet a été très largement
débattu de manière souvent passionnée
avec des propos
définitifs comme ceux du président de
pâté Jérôme Seydoux sur France Inter le
13 octobre dernier les gens je le cite
ne veulent pas aller au cinéma pour se
faire chier fin citation vous voyez on
est très loin de la poésie et de vos
poèmes et je m'en excuse comment vous
situez-vous dans ce débat merci Madame
administré
Sabine drixler pour les crédits
alors les réglementations thermiques qui
résultent de la loi climat et résilience
nécessite d'identifier de rénover les
biens énergivores ces nouvelles règles
notamment le diagnostic du performance
énergétique s'avère dramatique pour le
patrimoine bâti qu'il s'agisse de celui
qui fait l'objet de protection ou du
petit patrimoine de nos régions nos
maisons à pans de bois ou de pierre en
effet les modalités du DPE ne tiennent
aucun compte de la valeur patrimoniale
des biens les mêmes calculs et les mêmes
préconisations s'appliquent au bâtiment
construit entre 1948 et le premier choc
pétrolier les plus énergivores et à se
construit auparavant notamment aux
maisons anciennes qui ont des qualités
d'isolation qui leur sont propres liées
à leur orientation matériaux utilisés
pour leur construction et surtout à leur
inertie qui leur permet globalement
d'obtenir des performances énergétiques
tout à fait acceptables
ces normes d'isolation préconisées sans
nuances sont de véritables aubaines pour
les professionnels de l'isolation qui
n'hésitent pas à étouffer des
architectures remarquables sous des
plaques de polystyrène sans tenir compte
de leur caractéristiques hygrohermiques
aubaine également pour les constructeurs
qui rachètent au prix du terrain des
maisons inhabitées et dégradées fautes
de pouvoir être loué maison qui finiront
démolis et remplacés par des
constructions neuves dans le cadre de la
mise en oeuvre du zan alors que celui-ci
pourrait être une opportunité pour la
réhabilitation et la réaffectation du
patrimoine bâti on obtient les fins
inverses et force est de constater que
dans la perspective de ces mesures bon
nombre de maisons déjà fait les frais de
ce que certains qualifient de
malentendus réglementaires alors madame
la ministre dans ce contexte quelles
sont les mesures envisagées par votre
ministère pour contribuer à la
préservation du bâti ancien celui qui
confère à notre pays l'identité qui est
la sienne et qui contribue à
l'attractivité touristique dynamisme
économique de nos régions contenu de
l'urgence comment allez-vous mettre fin
à l'application de ces mesures et
stopper cette hécatombe ma deuxième
question concerne les services du
patrimoine au niveau des concentrés la
meilleure manière de préserver et de
sauvegarder le patrimoine consiste à
l'entretenir et à le restaurer or ce
type de travaux nécessite une expertise
dans nos collectivités en particulier
les plus petites ne disposent pas ni
d'ailleurs les propriétaires privés
l'absence d'aide à la maîtrise
d'ouvrages étaient handicap qui conduit
certains à renoncer à leurs projets et
paradoxalement à la non-consommation des
crédits affectés au patrimoine alors
même que l'urgence des travaux reste
avéré l'an dernier déjà la Cour des
comptes et le rapport du Sénat pointait
le manque de moyens humains des Dracs et
des USAP les ABF en nombre insuffisants
ne sont plus en mesure de remplir leur
mission du Conseil et sont de ce fait
souvent mal perçus notamment par les
particuliers qui ne comprennent pas
toujours le sens de leur préconisations
madame la ministre quelles sont les
perspectives en termes d'effectif des
services déconcentrés de l'État quels
moyens envisagez-vous de mettre en
oeuvre pour permettre à ces personnels
de mieux remplir leur mission de
conseils
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
moi je vais me féliciter de la hausse du
budget de la culture même si des
inquiétudes demeurent et je voudrais en
exprimer quelques-unes
la première viendra de celle que nous
venons d'entendre de la part du ministre
de l'Intérieur Darmanin je l'avais
entendu lors de mes auditions je ne
l'avais pas d'ailleurs anticipé c'est
celle de la difficulté de tenue d'un
certain nombre de grands événements
culturels lors des JO 2024 je les avais
entendus notamment par un certain nombre
d'acteurs lors des auditions mais les
propos de du ministre Darmanin je vous
l'avoue ne m'ont pas rassuré et donc je
voudrais que vous nous garantissiez
qu'il y ait vraiment une anticipation en
interministériel qui n'y est pas une
année blanche pour les festivals qui n'y
est pas de non dialogue avec les élus et
les porteurs de projets je pense que il
faut différencier Paris et
l'Île-de-France et que le reste des
territoires où il va se passer
effectivement où il se passe normalement
un certain nombre d'événements culturels
ne seront pas
je disais pendant le confinement en
silence pendant cette période là
deuxième question c'est c'est
l'inquiétude qui vient forcément liée à
l'énergie et à l'augmentation des
factures je voudrais que vous sur le
bouclier énergétique que vous nous
disiez si vous considérez que les
critères sont adaptés au secteur de la
création singulièrement concernant
l'emploi sur le plafond des 10 salariés
par exemple est-ce que les intermittents
sont comptabilisés dans le plafond une
autre question est-ce que la référence à
2019 qui n'est pas du tout adaptée
puisqu'en 2019 et bien les lieux
culturels étaient fermés va rester comme
une année de référence ça va jouer
forcément dans la question de ce
bouclier énergétique deuxième question
troisième question mais le président
Laffont vous l'a déjà posé mais j'irai
plus loin le fond d'innovation
territoriale est-ce que vous avez donné
des consignes au DRAC pour que y ait un
certain nombre peut-être de de priorité
donnée je pense au secteur rural par
exemple mais ça peut être autre chose et
surtout afin d'éviter la baisse des dans
le contexte de crise actuelle est-ce que
vous pensez contractualiser avec les
collectivités territoriales enfin et je
termine sur les arts visuels
avez-vous un bilan chiffré de mon
nouveau et notamment parce que lors de
mes auditions il y aurait une alerte sur
le fait que la plupart des projets
auraient été produit par les mêmes
agences et notamment qui sont basés en
Île-de-France voilà ce président madame
la ministre mais mes quelques questions
je vous remercie et enfin pour cette
première série de questions Vincent
aimer que je salue et qui rapporteur
spécial
de des crédits de la culture pour la
commission des finances merci monsieur
le Président merci de votre accueil
certes traditionnel mais enfin qui est
toujours plaisant pour nous de venir à
la rencontre de nos collègues de la
commission des affaires culturelles
madame le ministre je voudrais dans mon
intervention
[Musique]
vous faire une une observation une
remarque et puis questionner sur un
sujet qui me paraît tout à fait
important
l'observation elle est relative à la
situation dans laquelle j'allais dire
nous sommes mais enfin surtout les
acteurs et les institutions de la
culture
au lendemain d'une crise assez durable
et très perturbante pour la conduite des
activités culturelles singulièrement
beaucoup
de
d'acteurs du monde des arts et de la
culture ce sont trouvés précarisés avec
des situations individuelles mais aussi
bien sûr collectives l'une ne va pas
sans l'autre c'est vrai pour les
compagnies les institutions etc les
musées qui sont parfois en grande
difficulté et pour les moins
soutenu par l'action publique je veux
dire pour les acteurs privés ça confine
parfois
l'obligation de réduire l'activité voire
de l'interrompre l'année 2023 si on se
tourne vers l'avenir elle se place sous
le trouble le triple signe de
l'inflation de la hausse du coup de
l'énergie et du retour malheureusement
parfois très partiel du public dans les
lieux d'art et de culture
et pour cela la progression dont vous
vous félicitez de cette pour cent il est
vrai qu'on ne la trouve pas sur tous les
segments de l'action publique cette
augmentation de 7% nous nous l'observons
comme à peine supérieure à celle
attendue de l'inflation donc finalement
ce n'est quand même pas j'irai une
perspective extrêmement rassurante ça
c'était pour l'observation et puis la
question c'est en m'éloignant de ce qui
est traité par ailleurs et excellente
par nombre de mes collègues
qui s'intéresse bien naturellement je ne
leur en fais pas reproche à la situation
nationale c'est peut-être de vous poser
la question parce que il me semble
du moins beaucoup d'observateurs le
disent votre égard votre parcours votre
identité font que vous vous intéressez à
la question de la présence française
dans l'international
et c'est une question évidemment
absolument
déterminante
l'action culturelle internationale parce
que si la France évidemment est
influente par son économie si elle est
influente j'irai par sa diplomatie elle
l'est aussi et au combien par sa
présence culturelle partout dans le
monde ou dans de très nombreuses régions
du monde
de ce point de vue il y a une
augmentation de crédit là encore c'est
c'est 0,7 millions d'euros pour les
crédits qui sont portés par le
secrétariat général de votre ministère
sur un budget qui était je crois autour
de 7 millions donc on est à
une fraction qui n'est pas négligeable
mais enfin voilà ça va pas non plus
bouleverser totalement la donne donc
quelles sont vos priorités en matière
d'action culturelle internationale et
quelle est la philosophie de votre
action dans ce domaine merci
madame la ministre cette première série
de questions
merci beaucoup
concernant l'audioel public merci
beaucoup monsieur Hugonnet pour vos
interventions
récurrentes en soutien à cette
audiovisuel et à ses réformes pour
s'adapter aux enjeux de demain
les contrats d'objectifs et de moyens
ils ont été effectivement prolongés d'un
an sauf pour Arte où ces deux ans pour
s'aligner avec nos amis allemands
donc on
a là un avenant qui va être fait de
manière vraiment d'ajustement très
technique pour le comme 2023 et comme je
le dis toujours ce sont d'abord les
missions les objectifs les enjeux la
vision d'avenir dont on doit discuter
avant de commencer à discuter de la
trajectoire dans le détail pour les
années qui viennent et donc j'espère que
les candidats et les candidates pour
France media monde et pour Radio France
sont bien dans cet état d'esprit de
présenter d'abord une vision votre jeu
qui nécessiteront ensuite une discussion
budgétaire et on le sait la discussion
avec l'État actionnaire souvent les
entreprises demandent plus demandent des
moyens supplémentaires et après c'est en
fonction des priorités qu'elles
affichent des réformes qu'elle souhaite
faire des synergies qu'elles peuvent
développer davantage ou pas ensemble
qu'on peut travailler avec elle sur sur
le budget d'ailleurs là la répartition
des dotations de cette hausse de 114
millions en fait elle s'est faite en
totale concertation avec les groupes de
lotusel public en partant de leur copie
si je puis dire de leur plan d'affaires
pour le dire autrement
donc voilà on la répartit aussi il y a
aussi des enjeux importants sur le dieu
à l'extérieur qu'on a qu'on a voulu dont
on a voulu tenir compte mais France
Télévisions a quand même plus 24
millions d'euros on a tenu compte à
chaque fois des effets fiscaux pour les
neutraliser on a tenu à chaque fois du
glissement des des dépenses aussi la
matière de ma salariale pour en prendre
une grande partie donc je pense qu'il y
a un travail assez fin qui a été fait
y compris jusqu'à la dernière minute en
ajustant avec chacun d'entre eux et il
me semble que voilà on a abouti à
quelque chose qui est assez consensuel
avec chacune des entreprises
concernant la presse merci au sénateur
Laugier de nous rappeler cet enjeu vital
pour notre démocratie
sachant que vraiment je pense que on
peut se réjouir de se plant de filière
qu'on a pu déployer pendant le plan de
relance qui est c'est élevé à 377
millions d'euros qui a permis
d'accompagner la transition numérique de
la presse la transition écologique qui a
permis de créer un fond aussi de
résorption de la précarité pour les
journalistes bref à plein de niveaux ce
plan de filaire a été déterminant là on
engage cette réforme de la distribution
évidemment nous voilà percutés par la
flambée du coup du papier sachant que
les entreprises ont déjà accès aux
bouclier tarifaires de droit commun si
je puis dire mais effectivement en plus
des hausses du prix du gaz et de
l'électricité s'ajoutent la flambée du
coup du papier donc effectivement il y a
des discussions suite à l'amendement qui
a été déposé
c'est
c'est quand même complexe parce que
énormément de secteurs sont impactés par
des inflations pas uniquement le papier
je pense dans d'autres domaines de
l'industrie dont je suis moins la
spécialiste en tout cas ça va être une
discussion globale avec mon collègue
Bruno Le Maire pour voir comment
accompagner mieux ce secteur les
co-contribution je pense est un enjeu
crucial c'est effectivement deux pistes
possibles soit remonter au créneau
auprès de la Commission européenne soit
sortir la presse de ce régime de
responsabilité élargie du producteur
nous sommes en tout cas côté ministère
de la Culture favorable à trouver une
solution et nous sommes en train
d'avancer sur ces deux hypothèses nous
pourrons vous en dire plus très bientôt
je rejoins aussi l'inquiétude du
sénateur barjoton concernant les maisons
d'édition il n'y a pas que la presque
impactée par le coût du papier mais
aussi des maisons d'édition qui sont
amenées à faire parfois des choix
imprimés avec des polices plus petites
ou renoncer voire même à certains
ouvrages qui peut être préoccupant
là aussi nous allons regarder au cas par
cas avec le Centre national du livre qui
soutient notamment les petits éditeurs
les grosses maisons d'édition sont quand
même il me semble en bonne santé
aujourd'hui même si elles sont impactées
par le coup du papier elles n'ont pas la
même situation que la filière presse
avec une année 2020 une année 2021 qui
ont été relativement exceptionnelles
l'année 2022 - C'est vrai depuis la
guerre en Ukraine on sent
infléchissement depuis le mois de mars
mais une rentrée littéraire très forte
un prix Nobel à Asnières nous dont on
peut être très fier qui dope aussi les
ventes pour Gallimard en tout cas et qui
aide nos libraires donc c'est tout un
écosystème en fait qui est soutenu
effectivement dans le plan de relance de
nombreuses aides ont été déployées pour
les librairies
pour aussi en plus du Pass Culture faire
cette opération jeune en librairie qui
est plus une opération sur le long terme
qui avait été initié en région
nouvelle-aquitaine et que nous avons
étendu à plusieurs régions je n'ai pas
le bilan précis sous les yeux mais je
vous le transmettrai dès que possible
merci aussi d'avoir appelé que la Cour
des comptes s'est penchée avec précision
sur la gestion du chantier de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris et à
saluer une gestion visiblement
impeccable et des délais tenus pour
l'instant par rapport aux prévisions
donc je ne peux que me réjouir de ces de
ces conclusions de la cour et renouveler
ma confiance au général Georges lin qui
mène d'une main
de mettre
ce chantier
monsieur le sénateur batchy sur les
cinémas merci de me donner l'occasion de
développer un peu plus tout ce que nous
nous déployons pour le soutien à ce
secteur à un moment effectivement où la
baisse de fréquentation est préoccupante
d'ailleurs pour le spectacle vivant
aussi pour le cinéma nous sommes en
moyenne 25 28% de baisse de
fréquentation donc c'est un quart de
public d'avant covid qui n'est pas
revenu dans les salles mais il y a tout
de même une situation bien meilleure en
France qu'ailleurs c'est important de
regarder ce qui se passe chez nos
voisins moins 60% de fréquentation en
Italie moins 40% en Espagne moins 40% en
Allemagne pour citer que ces trois
exemples donc notre
écosystème à mieux résister et le peuple
français est plus cinéphile et c'est
tout de même une bonne nouvelle même si
ça n'est pas suffisant pour la vitalité
de notre industrie donc à court terme
nous avons décidé de soutenir une
campagne de communication à hauteur d'un
million d'euros d'ailleurs je vous en
montre en avant-première je sais pas si
vous arrivez à lire une des affiches on
a tous une bonne raison d'aller au
cinéma et vous quelle est la vôtre vous
pourrez dès demain c'est demain qu'elle
commence vous aussi relayez sur vos
réseaux votre bonne raison d'aller au
cinéma pour justement faire rêver et
redonner envie aux Français de vivre
l'émotion en grand dans une salle de
cinéma et voir les films sur grand écran
ce qui est sans commune mesure avec le
fait de regarder un film chez soi ou sur
tablette ou sur ordinateur on est bien
d'accord
les raisons de cette baisse de
fréquentation elles sont multiples il y
a évidemment la perte d'habitude suite
au confinement au couvre-feu il y a ce
que moi j'appelle la plateformeisation
de nos vies
voilà de nouvelles habitudes ont été
prises de regarder les plateformes il y
a une perception des tarifs vous l'avez
rappelé le tarif moyen en France et 7
euros j'ai regardé le tarif moyen en
Allemagne c'est 8,90 donc quasiment neuf
euros donc on est pas si cher en france
il y a énormément de tarifs réduits dans
les salles de cinéma mais il y a
toujours cette perception que le cinéma
est cher donc il y a un effort à faire
pour bien expliquer l'ensemble des
tarifs réduits qui sont disponibles
et il y a je pense une une part qui
vient du télétravail je pense que les
changements d'habitudes viennent du fait
qu'une fois qu'on est chez soi en train
de travailler on ressort moins
facilement notamment pour aller au
cinéma
et on a la question d'une forme
d'exigence
je n'irai pas jusqu'à reprendre la
formule de Monsieur sedou vous avez cité
mais il y a une exigence du public pour
plus peut-être de qualité plus
d'originalité des œuvres elles existent
les films français sont d'une grande
diversité d'une grande originalité d'une
grande singularité il y a des films
français là en ce moment qui
fonctionnent très très bien j'ai regardé
les chiffres de novembre Simon
l'innocent ce sont des films qui
démarrent très très bien donc on voit
bien là pour ces vacances de la
Toussaint que nous concitoyens
l'embarras du choix de bons films à
aller voir et moi je préfère avoir ce
discours volontariste et optimiste sans
compter toutes les aides que nous
continuons à déployer pendant la crise
sanitaire c'était 300 millions d'euros
les aides au cinéma dont 220 uniquement
pour les salles donc très important
bouclier
filet de sécurité pour notre filière
et nous poursuivons ces efforts
je me tourne vers la signatrice dexler
pardon pour les sujets très précis
complet que vous avez soulevé sur cette
conciliation nécessaire entre patrimoine
énergies renouvelable transition
écologique isolation thermique
il me faudrait plusieurs heures pour y
travailler avec vous mais je vois bien
les points que vous soulevez nous nous
sommes là en train de travailler par
exemple sur le photovoltaïque avec le
ministère de la transition écologique
pour
rédiger une instruction ministérielle
pour que nos ABS est un cadre de travail
à partir duquel avoir des catégories
pour
évaluer plus précisément dans quel cas
on peut mettre des panneaux
photovoltaïques il y a des innovations
aussi sur des nouveaux types de panneaux
photovoltaïques qui peuvent être prises
en compte bref sur chaque sujet que ce
soit les fenêtres que ce soit
différentes formes d'isolation que ce
soit le photovoltaïque on a comme ça une
expertise aussi de nos architectes des
sentiment de France puisque l'enjeu est
pas de entre guillemets faire n'importe
quoi et avoir une
une installation trop disparate qui
abîme le patrimoine on doit pouvoir
concilier les deux vous avez soulevé
plusieurs questions importantes j'espère
pouvoir vous fournir des réponses plus
complètes une prochaine fois
merci à Sylvie Robert d'avoir soulevé
ces deux sujets des festivals et plus
globalement de de l'inquiétude sur
l'inflation du coût de l'énergie
concernant les Jeux Olympiques
c'est une formidable opportunité pour la
France d'avoir les Jeux Olympiques en
2024 c'est aussi l'occasion
de construire un projet culturel
ambitieux autour de ce de ces JO nous
nous avons décidé avec Amélie ou desa
Castéra et le comité des Jeux olympiques
de lancer les Olympiades culturelles
elles ont déjà démarré elles vont se
poursuivre en 2023 jusqu'à mi-2024
l'objet 2023 prévoit d'ailleurs 3
millions d'euros pour ces olympiades et
le comité des Jeux Olympiques prévoit
lui-même avec Dominic Hervieux comme
directrice artistique ancienne
directrice de la Maison de la Danse de
Lyon un programme assez ambitieux de
concert d'événements qui vont nécessiter
aussi des installations techniques des
forces de sécurité et s'ajoutent à cela
les festivals habituels de l'été qui
font l'ADN au fond de la France
culturelle de l'été
donc il est très important de voir
l'impact en France en Île-de-France et
ailleurs de les coûts techniques pour
les festivals parce que déjà certains
m'alert sur des pénuries de matériel des
locations déjà bloquées pour les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
la nécessité de ce coordonnées avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur pour les forces
de sécurité même quand il s'agit de
sécurité privée certaines sont déjà
réservées pour des événements des Jeux
Olympiques donc il y a là une pression
pour nos festivals et je vais être très
mobilisé sur ce sujet pour tenter de
trouver des solutions évidemment
concernant l'inflation je vous ai donné
un peu le montant de 56 millions d'euros
qui est celui que nous avons à
disposition pour le budget 2023 qui va
être destiné vraiment au cas et plus
critique et en priorité je dois le dire
pour les établissements nationaux car
eux sont soutenus que par l'État donc il
n'y a en priorité ce sera eux puis les
autres qui ont des difficultés parce que
leur bâtiment sont des passoires
thermiques absolues en revanche dans
l'ensemble des autres cas nous nous
maintenons partout partout nos
subventions il n'y a aucune baisse de
subventions de l'État il y aura même des
hausses au cas par cas selon les régions
y compris là où il y a des baisses de
certaines collectivités nous essay de
venir en aide à des structures je pense
à la Villa gilet à Lyon par exemple à
qui nous avons augmenté la subvention
parce qu'elle a été coupée drastiquement
par le Conseil Régional Auvergne
Rhône-Alpes mais nous ne pouvons pas
compenser partout toutes les baisses des
collectivités c'est un vrai sujet
vous avez parlé du bilan de mon nouveau
et j'ai peur qu'il y ait une confusion
entre les agences de production qui
aident les projets à se faire en fait il
y a trois catégories de projets il y a
les projets qui sont qui ont lieu dans
les monuments du sang des monuments
nationaux il y a des projets qui ont
lieu dans les sites naturels du
Conservatoire du littoral et il y a
d'autres projets un tiers qui sont
situés dans d'autres types de lieux un
EHPAD une cour d'école une université
une place publique etc pour ces projets
il y avait besoin d'une agence en
production qui accompagne les artistes
certains sont très très jeunes ont 20
ans 22 ans n'ont pas la capacité à
construire la production des projets
donc ces agents sont effectivement basés
à Paris mais le budget de mon nouveau va
à tous les projets qui ont été retenus
il y en a 264 et qui sont partout en
France et qui permettent de soutenir 450
artistes par exemple en Bretagne il y a
34 projets qui sont soutenus en haut de
France 21 en nouvelle-aquitaine 14 35 en
provençale-côte d'Azur je pourrais vous
donner tous les détails on a une très
bonne répartition géographique en
outre-mer également par exemple 12 en
Martinique 6 à la Réunion
600 Guadeloupe quatre en Guyane etc même
un projet à Mayotte alors qu'on avait du
mal à trouver des projets à Mayotte
et on a une répartition assez équitable
aussi entre les disciplines artistiques
ce qui est intéressant dans mon nouveau
c'est aussi la mobilisation de collectif
beaucoup de jeunes artistes ont proposé
des projets à cheval sur plusieurs
disciplines la danse et l'architecture
le design et la musique etc et donc on a
26% des projets qui sont en fait
pluridisciplinaires portés par des
collectifs et sinon se répartissent de
manière très équitable entre les arts
visuels le spectacle vivant le
l'écriture la littérature etc
pour finir je voulais juste dire au
sénateurs meublé monsieur le rapporteur
spécial que vous avez dit que la hausse
du budget ne couvrait pas l'inflation
mais l'inflation nous sur laquelle nous
ne sommes basés c'est celle estimés par
la Banque de France à 4,2 % pour 2023
donc avec un budget en hausse de 7 % on
est quand même au dessus quant à l'enjeu
de la langue française et de l'Action
française à l'international c'est
évidemment un enjeu très important pour
moi que nous portons à deux avec le
ministère des Affaires étrangères
puisque une grande partie de ces crédits
sont en fait du côté du ministère de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères qui
chapotent ce réseau culturel français à
l'étranger qui a la tutelle avec nous de
l'Institut français qui déploie cette
action dans notre budget 2023 nous
mettons l'action sur plusieurs choses
d'une part je tiens beaucoup au réseau
des librairies francophones qui sont
absolument vitales pour continuer à
diffuser le livre en langue française
donc là par exemple j'ai débloqué une
aide de 500.000 euros à 4 librairies qui
allait faire faillite au Liban au Brésil
au nous allons continuer notre soutien
en librairie francophone via le Centre
national du livre le soutien à la
distribution du livre aussi via la
centrale de l'édition on a rajouté un
million d'euros c'est à la fois pour
l'international et pour la France en
outre-mer le soutien la traduction le
soutien au projet littéraire avec
notamment un nouveau programme
issu du sommet des deux rives qui
s'appelle livre des deux rives qui relie
la France et les pays du Maghreb pour
soutenir des projets littéraires des
éditions en langue française et des
traductions
au Maghreb pour citer quelques exemples
et évidemment le projet de
Villers-Cotterêts qui va nous mobiliser
dans les prochains mois avec une
ouverture prévue au public au printemps
2023 cette Cité internationale de la
langue française au cœur des Hauts de
France de l'Aisne ancien château de
François 1er ville de naissance
d'Alexandre Dumas terre de littérature
va pouvoir accueillir des artistes des
écrivains du monde entier du monde
francophone va pouvoir déployer des
projets aussi avec des associations
locales d'apprentissage du français des
projets avec des entreprises qui sont à
la pointe en France des technologies de
la langue de la traduction donc on a là
un beau projet devant nous pour porter
aussi cette ambition pour la langue
française
merci Madame la Ministre on va prendre
une deuxième série de questions une
dernière sur les questions en commençant
par elle ce Joseph
pardon
excusez-moi je peux l'habitude madame la
ministre
j'ai une petite question enfin j'aurais
deux questions une qui concerne les
festivals je constate que les festivals
ont fait preuve d'une incroyable qualité
dans le cadre de la reprise des
activités culturelles suite à la crise
sanitaire il figure parmi les premiers
diffuseurs de de la culture dans les
territoires et joue un rôle essentiel
dans l'écosystème culturel le groupe
d'études salut le travail amorcé avec
les trois actes des États généraux des
festivals pour réaffirmer le rôle de
l'État et sa politique à destination des
festivals la mise en place d'un nouveau
fond festival est une bonne nouvelle
même si sa dotation de 10 millions
d'euros par an qui est annoncé jusqu'en
2024 reste insuffisante pour couvrir les
besoins des 7300 festivals cartographiés
donc quelle est la prochaine étape
concernant l'évolution de cette
politique publique de nouvelles
priorités devraient-elles être définie à
courte et moyen terme et l'État
entront-ils débloquer des nouveaux
moyens budgétaires pour accompagner les
festivals même si j'ai bien noté tout à
l'heure le rôle pouvait jouer le loto du
patrimoine
pardon je suis en train
j'anticipe sur la deuxième question que
je vais vous poser donc la deuxième
question elle concerne cette fois-ci les
crédits du plan de relance puisque
j'avais été co-rapporteur avec Olivier
Pacaud donc justement sur les crédits du
plan de relance consacré au patrimoine
on avait apprécié évidemment tous les
efforts accomplis majoritairement tourné
vers le patrimoine national vous avez
évoqué à l'instant ville etcré bon mais
la France dispose aussi également d'un
autre patrimoine qui appartient à
d'autres à d'autres acteurs et qui
consacrent de nombreux moyens pour son
entretien donc je voulais savoir ce qui
était prévu pour les autres monuments
qui n'appartenaient pas à l'état qu'il
s'agisse des monuments qui relèvent de
patrimoine enfin de propriétaires privés
ou ceux qui relèvent de collectivités
locales et c'est donc là j'évoque le
rôle évidemment ici du Loto du
patrimoine voilà mes deux questions
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
madame la ministre plusieurs plusieurs
questions mais certaines ont déjà été
évoqués notamment par Sabine Dressler
sur le rôle des Dracs dans
l'accompagnement des collectivités et
monsieur le Président nous a fait
l'honneur à Ventalon et votre serviteur
de de cité de notre rapport sur les
édifices religieux qui met en lumière en
effet un certain nombre de phénomènes et
surtout la la façon dont les mers se
sentent complètement désemparés pour
pouvoir mobiliser les services de l'État
et les financements pour rénover leur
leur patrimoine donc ça pose la question
plus générale de l'action décentralisée
de l'État et on s'est aperçu avec ma
collègue inventalon que en matière
d'inventaire aujourd'hui il y a autant
de politiques d'inventaire qui a de
puisque la compétence est
décentralisée mais la somme de ces
politiques régionales ne fait pas une
politique nationale et on sent très bien
que dans des domaines très précis je
vais vous donner un exemple celui des
synagogues alsacienne que nous avons
signalé dans notre rapport comme quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui mériterait toute
l'attention de l'État parce que c'est un
patrimoine qui va qui va disparaître or
c'est un patrimoine qui témoigne de ce
que de ce qui a été le judaïsme
notamment dans dans le Haut-Rhin
constitutif de notre identité et je
crois que c'est important de réaffirmer
si on ne fait rien ces synagogues elles
vont être vendues et transformées il y
aura pu aucune trace de ce de ce qui a
été cette culture en Alsace et notamment
dans dans le Haut-Rhin donc là on a
besoin que le mystère de la culture il
imprime des grands axes alors sur
l'archéologie
depuis quelques temps c'est la première
fois que l'archéologie autant cité dans
un discours d'une ministre donc je peux
je peux pas dire grand chose
si ce n'est que
s'agissant de l'INRAP il y a quand même
un effet ciseaux qui peut être
redoutable l'INRAP subit comme tous les
opérateurs la hausse
il y a l'énergie à l'inflation mais par
ailleurs le plan de relance a fait qu'il
y a une demande beaucoup plus forte de
diagnostic que l'INRAP ne peut pas
réaliser avec les moyens qu'il a donc
eux souhaiteraient que de façon
temporaire notamment sur ces demandes de
diagnostic supplémentaires ils puissent
dépasser leur plafond d'emploi sinon le
le risque c'est qu'on se retrouve de
nouveau avec un conflit entre les
collectivités et l'INRAP qui n'a pas les
moyens financiers de réaliser les
diagnostics et les fouilles ensuite pour
pour finir vous avez cité Frédérico
Garcia Lorca Dieu le fracas que fait un
poète contenu a dit le poète et j'en
viens à l'Europe de la culture et à
Georges Amélie
la filiation est directe malheureusement
Fratelli d'Italia a dit de façon très
claire qu'il fallait une culture d'État
qui fallait que la culture se mette au
service du récit national et que il
pouvait remplacer des fonctionnaires qui
ne respecteraient pas cette cette règle
donc on sent que est en train de se
mettre en place en Europe des choses qui
pourraient s'apprendre s'apparenter à un
art officiel ou au réalisme soviétique
là il y a une forme de totalarisme
culturel qui insupportable donc vous me
permettrez de citer gramship pour finir
puisque madame Meloni se réclame
à payer de sa vie
sur son indépendance d'esprit je cite
grinchi se connaitre soi-même signifie
être maître de soi se différencier se
dégager du chaos être un élément d'ordre
mais un élément de son ordre propre et
de sa propre discipline à l'égard d'un
idéal et tout ceci ne peut s'obtenir
sans connaître aussi les autres leur
histoire la succession des efforts
qu'ils ont fait pour être ce qu'ils sont
pour créer la civilisation qu'ils ont
créé merci Madame ministre
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre d'abord je voudrais vous
féliciter parce que vous êtes une grande
mise à culture qui parle enfin lors de
cette audition budgétaire annuelle de
l'action extérieure de l'État en tout
cas de la politique culturelle à
l'étranger je trouve ça très important
parce que notre commission vote à la
fois les crédits bien entendu ces
crédits tout comme la commission des
affaires étrangères mais rares ont été
les occasions de dialoguer en direct
avec le ou la ministre de la Culture sur
cette politique qui est très importante
parce qu'elle est liée aussi à notre
boutique nationale souvent les ensembles
que nous accompagnons à travers
notamment ou les compagnies travers
l'Institut français et bien ils œuvrent
aussi sur le territoire national il y a
forcément des connaissions et les
stratégies aussi à
développer donc j'étais intéressé par
les propos que vous avez tenu
j'ai une question qui va porter sur les
enseignements artistiques madame la
ministre j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'évoquer le sujet parce que je vous
entends ça fait deux reprises de vous
entendre votre commission parler de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle qui
est pour moi une sensibilisation
permanente des arts et à la culture aux
arrêts de la culture mais je nous ai pas
entendu parler d'enseignements
artistique alors je voudrais savoir
quelle est la différence pour vous entre
les les deux terminologistes qu'elles
recouvre comme réalité de politiques
publiques si je dis ça c'est pour vous
alerter une nouvelle fois et j'en ai
parlé avec plusieurs collègues de la
Commission on partage cette
préoccupation qui est le devenir de nos
écoles d'art et de nos conservatoires
car il ne serait y avoir l'éducation
artistique il n'y a pas non plus des
enseignements artistiques qui
dot un certain nombre de jeunes
concitoyens concitoyennes d'une
formation technique parce que c'est ça
aussi les enseignements artistiques et
qui par la suite permettront justement
le déploiement de l'éducation artistique
culturelle et puis elle fournir à la
fois nos troupes nos orchestres nos
scènes nos salles les lieux et aussi de
vie que les jeunes concitoyens sont
amenés à fréquenter or ces
établissements sont en très grande
souffrance depuis pratiquement 20 ans
rares sont les ministre de la Culture
qui sont préoccupés de leur sort moi je
le dis maintenant comme je le pense nous
le disons comme nous le pensons depuis
le temps que nous sions dans cette
commission on a vu même jusqu'à
disparaître complètement les budgets
dédiés conservatoires pour être établi
mais pas dans leur complétude quelques
années après et ces établissements pour
lesquels d'ailleurs les collectivités
principalement les communes et les
intercommunalités
agissent se voient bloqué parce que
aussi les lois de décentralisation ne
sont pas accompagnées par le ministère
et qui a fort besoin si on doit reparler
de décentralisation j'ai entendu madame
borne est très allande sur ce sujet il
va bien falloir reparler la
décentralisation des enseignes
artistiques et que le ministère de la
culture soit très moteur et parti
prenante avec les collectivités
territoriales les directeurs les
directrices sont en très grande
souffrance d'aucun démissionne ou
abandonne le métier
souvent ces établissements sont
confondus à juste titre avec des
établissements élitistes on excellent et
élitiste c'est pas la même chose ces
établissements d'ailleurs ont su évolué
pour se doter de mission complémentaires
et très ouvertes sur la cité ce sont des
pôles ressources pour les territoires de
référence donc il méritent vraiment
qu'on les accompagne et qu'on accompagne
une nécessaire évolution pour assurer
leur devenir voilà c'est ma question
est-ce que dans cette loi de finance
madame la ministre on jette un regard
particulier sur ces établissements qui
en ont bien besoin et qui comptent sur
vous certainement puisque vous venez de
prendre vos fonctions
au nom de Sonia de la provoquer la
première question concerne les écoles
nationales d'architecture outre le
contexte qui augmente la contrainte
budgétaire des établissements il y a un
impact réel des politiques publiques en
matière de développement durable dont le
défi thermique engendrant une
modification très importante du métier
d'architecte Madame le Ministre pour ce
métier
vital avez-vous prévu un plan de
développement de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche en
architecture et ce qu'on
interministérielle notamment écologie
logement territoire les change
fonctionne suffisamment pour
co-construire ce plan et puis deuxième
question sur le patrimoine par ailleurs
le budget patrimoine montre cette année
une aggravation de la facture financière
entre la participation de l'État pour
Paris et l'Île-de-France ou détriment
des autres villes et régions je cite
Sonia de la pauvreté je ne dis pas mon
même si l'effet de levier des
collectivités sans commune mesure en
région est très supérieure et pour
autant légitime que le regard et
l'accompagnement du ministère soit si
déséquilibré David la souligne
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre c'est rare que pour tous les
cas j'ai eu à le faire
pour dire que une augmentation certes
que je vais pondérer derrière mais de
7%, c'est dans un contexte
difficile quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument saluer on voit que vous savez
négocier les budgets vous étiez à des
places ou plutôt vous arbitiez à la
baisse mais vous êtes obligés de monter
au front pour obtenir plus et vous savez
faire mais je sais que j'ai dû y compris
sous un gouvernement que je soutenais
m'insurger sur le fait qu'on puisse
baisser les crédits de ce secteur pour
dire que voilà je suis plutôt satisfait
mais
je veux mettre en garde avec la façon et
la communication que vous en faites
parce que non pas parce que c'est un peu
normal que vous magnifiez les choses
mais surtout parce que ça peut nous
faire baisser la garde quand il y a une
inflation à 4,2 une augmentation globale
de cette
ce n'est pas cette
c'est un peu plus de faut le savoir
pourquoi parce que les prévisions
d'inflation sont peut-être plus
importantes
et aussi parce que ça que ce cumule à
ses prévisions
ce que l'on sait de de grave que toutes
les collectivités territoriales nous
signale mais que ça va être pareil pour
tout le monde de la création à tous les
niveaux c'est que la hausse du coût de
l'énergie va s'additionner à l'inflation
et n'est pas comprise dedans et que les
factures sont dans certains secteurs
énormes parce que ce sont des secteurs
qui consomment beaucoup d'énergie et
donc voilà je veux le pondérer en disant
au moins il y aura pas de baisse la
deuxième critique que je ferais c'est
que malheureusement
dans cette affichage général il y a des
secteurs qui augmentent et il y a des
secteurs qui stagnent
et on ne comprend pas trop pourquoi et
je suis d'accord avec ces rares avec
monsieur le rapporteur de la commune de
de la mission média etc
Il a raison de dire bon ça mange pas de
pain d'augmenter de 10% même si c'est
bien Arte par exemple parce que le
budget est petit augmentation on fait un
fort pourcentage mais
français les visions a subi pendant
plusieurs années des baisses budgétaires
et là
c'est presque stagnant c'est 1% c'est en
dessous de l'inflation donc c'est une
baisse réelle une baisse dans les fêtes
et je vous passe les coups d'énergie
pour
France Télévisions parce que là il y a
beaucoup d'électricité
pour faire les programmes donc je je
peux reprendre y compris dans le secteur
de la presse dans le secteur dans tous
les secteurs la ventilation entre
entre les les
augmentations et inégale avec peu de
précision je veux juste
vous
interpeller
sur deux questions
vous nous rassurer vous avez
effectivement tenu parole sur le fait
que la redevance est compensée plus qu'à
l'euro près on va dire puisque la
prévision est large mais vous nous avez
toujours pas rassuré sur l'autre
critique que l'on faisait à la
suppression de la redevance c'est la
pérennité de ce financement et pour
l'instant
on ne sait pas donc on y reviendra parce
que sur la pérennité il n'y a pas encore
d'assurance et la dernière chose c'est
sur le secteur de la presse
il y a tout ce qui a dit mon collègue
rapporteur est vraiment je soutiens ce
qu'il a dit mais il y a un autre une
autre chose c'est que nous avons
fortement et notamment à travers des
propositions de la commission d'enquête
dont j'étais le rapporteur et Monsieur
Lafon était le président on a posé une
question où il y avait quasi consensus
de tout le milieu en tous les cas on a
réussi à faire un consensus nous donc
c'est pas mal pour dire que la
ventilation des aides à la presse
n'allait pas c'est-à-dire que vous nous
parlez en volume mais nous attendons une
réforme pour faire que ceux qui ont les
moyens et qui touchent le plus touchent
moins et que toutes les petits médias et
les nouveaux médias eux puissent
recevoir l'aide qu'ils n'ont pas
aujourd'hui ou si peu voilà donc on
aimerait qu'il y ait une refonte plus
juste
de ce qui est attribué indépendamment du
montant global parce que c'est ça qui
est qui est aujourd'hui attendu
Bernard fialer
oui moi je voudrais aussi saluer donc à
la fois l'augmentation du budget et même
les les grandes priorités que vous avez
donné à votre ministère mais j'aimerais
quelques exercices manges sur sur deux
points
moi je salue le fait que vous vouliez
attiré des nouveaux publics dans les
lieux culturels et en particulier les
jeunes
simplement
les jeunes
on sait que ils ont une utilisation
massive excessive même des écrans et
aujourd'hui cette utilisation vive les
réseaux sociaux majoritairement TikTok
mais aussi les jeux vidéo qu'on nous
présenterait comme une activité
culturelle mais qui peut quand même pas
être la seule et qui a plutôt des comme
conséquences une addiction et une
sédentarité à grandissante qui a des
vrais retentissements sur la santé
physique comme psychique des enfants
alors aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez faire concrètement pour que
justement les jeunes puissent bouger un
petit peu plus aller voir des spectacles
vivants découvrir
revenir à la lecture visiter des lieux
de culture et comment vous vous comptez
vous envisagez cela vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure des Olympiades
de la culture est-ce que vous voulez
comment vous compter associer à la fois
le ministère des Sports le ministère de
pour quand même bouger sortir un peu les
jeunes de de ces addictions le deuxième
point aussi vous avez parlé de votre
souhait de
garantir la fiabilité de l'information
alors vous savez aujourd'hui que il y a
un sondage sévipov qui dit seulement 29%
des sondés ont déclaré avoir confiance
dans les médias alors
cette perte de confiance et qui est
alimentée un peu par
plutôt pas d'information mais la
communication des réseaux sociaux
tous ces nouveaux médias quelle piste
vous envisagez pour garantir que
l'information est mise quand même par
nos médias soit vérifié fiable et
redonne confiance à nos concitoyens
c'est quand même un enjeu important de
la démocratie et de la société dans dans
laquelle on vit est-ce que vous pensez
que des réflexions sur
sur une déontologie pas seulement des
médias mais des journalistes puissent
aussi être envisagés Marie-Pierre
Monnier
merci monsieur le Président bonsoir
madame la ministre alors tout d'abord
une remarque la stagnation des crédits
en faveur des musées de patrimoine se
poursuit cette année
et cette stagnation s'inscrit dans un
contexte de forte inflation qui
interrogent alors que dans le même temps
les crédits de l'action patrimoine des
musées de France sont à 11 de 5%
donc merci de veiller à irriguer la
culture dans nos territoires au-delà des
grands musées nationaux le budget évoque
une reprise d'ailleurs de fréquentation
des institutions patrimoniales cette
année après deux ans de crise sanitaire
cette reprise est-elle homogène sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
ensuite une question sur les SPR avec
une stagnation des crédits prouvent
prévus pour les études des travaux en
SPR qui sont reconduits à 8,9 millions
d'euros depuis 2018 pourquoi c'est
enveloppe n'a-t-elle pas évolué
il y a eu en 22 une hausse budgétaire au
profit des CAE et du réseau ville et
d'art d'histoire qui maintenus comme à
deux je crois 6,5 millions d'euros comme
en 22 ce qui constitue une baisse réelle
contenue de l'inflation et nous sommes
pourtant nombreux à être très attachés
au rôle du CAE dont nous souhaiterions
une présence dans tous les départements
ils sont une aide précieuse pour les
mères en particulier ce des petites
communes qui font régulièrement appel
pour leur projet patrimoniaux et enfin
deux questions concernant les Dracs lors
d'une audition préparatoire à l'examen
du projet de loi de finance le président
de l'association des dragues de France
nous a alerté sur le manque
d'attractivité des professions à leur
sein qui conduit à laisser des postes
vacants notamment dans les territoires
avec comme conséquence une surcharge de
travail pour les personnels
effectivement en place
cette dynamique risque encore de
s'aggraver au bout d'une démographie
actuellement plutôt âgée nous a-t-il dit
nous a parlé de 12 postes ouverts et
seuls 4 sorties de Chaillots quels sont
les pistes envisagées par le ministère
pour répondre à ce difficile d'activités
et enfin depuis que la maîtrise
d'ouvrage des travaux sur les monuments
a été rendus aux propriétaires il est
prévu par le code du patrimoine que les
dragues peuvent exercer une assistance à
métisse d'ouvrages à titre onéreux ou
gratuit et le récent rapport de la Cour
des comptes intitulé la politique de
l'État en faveur du patrimoine
monumental établit pourtant que cette
disposition a eu très peu d'effets sur
le 3 dragues Bretagne aux deux France et
pays de Loire ont mis en place une
oeuvre qui demeure marginale ce rapport
souligne les limites d'initiatives
portées par d'autres acteurs en l'instar
des départements au regard de ce tableau
une évolution du cadre et donc des
effectifs associés au DRAC est-elle
envisagée je vous remercie
Monique de Marco
merci je vais aussi rajouter des
questions
c'est une première qui complète celle de
Sylvie Robert les salles de concert
comme de nombreuses entreprises sont
frappées de plein fouet par la crise
énergétique et pas la hausse des
factures le syndicat des musiques
actuelles a lancé une enquête auprès de
ses adhérents sur le sujet les premiers
résultats indiquent les salles font face
par rapport à 2021 à une hausse de plus
de 100% de leur facture énergétique et
de 87% de la facture de gaz
le problème c'est que ces entreprises
sont en dehors des dispositifs d'aide en
effet pour rappel il existe aujourd'hui
deux dispositifs le premier c'est le
bouclier tarifaire qui limite à 15%
d'augmentation de factures pour les
entreprises de moins de 10 salariés
faisant moins de 2 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires problème les salles
quand on compte les temps
complet les intérimaires sont en dessous
souvent de 10 salariés
le deuxième c'est l'aide spécifique pour
les entreprises qui consomment plus de
3% de fer
on sait que votre gouvernement
contrevoir ces dispositifs pourraient
inclure plus d'entreprises mais j'attire
surtout votre attention sur la question
des seuils pour que les salles de
concert puissent être ne pas être
oubliés ma deuxième question qui n'a pas
été posée puisqu'il faut aussi pouvoir
ouvrir je ne sais pas si vous aurez le
temps de répondre à tout le monde vous
annoncez un plan d'investissement d'un
million d'euros pour les industries
culturelles et créatives notamment les
technologies de metaves
il me semble que se pose une question
d'intérêt public et qu'il faut
distinguer les expériences culturelles
réalité virtuelle réalité augmentée avec
les opérations spéculatives telles que
l'arrivée des TNT c'est à dire des
systèmes de crypto monnaie sur le marché
de l'art
est-ce que le plan d'investissement d'un
milliard d'euros permettra de soutenir
aussi le développement de ces TNT
non pas dans excusez-moi NFT les non
fonctifs
[Musique]
vous annoncer un ministre que c'était
les dernières questions mais ça ne sera
pas le cas j'ai en ce qui me concerne
deux questions vous avez annoncé que le
budget de la culture est en augmentation
forte et nous sommes tous réjouis cette
hausse comme vous l'avez indiqué
concerne particulièrement le patrimoine
culturel de l'État avec plusieurs grands
projets et vous avez abondamment parlé
du château de villers-cottery du
Villers-Cotterêts au sujet duquel notre
commission vous le savez a eu l'occasion
de mettre cet homme de réserve quant aux
projets muséal nous avons parfois
souligné son côté un peu hors sol ils
sont son côté projet présidentiel un peu
surprenant à l'heure de la sobriété donc
qu'en est-il de la trajectoire
financière du chantier de ses éventuels
déplacements de l'état de son exécution
et nous pensez-vous pas que ce projet
n'est pas facteur de déséquilibre avec
le sous diète dont on aurait besoin
notre réseau de sortes culturel et
d'instituts à travers le monde qui
souvent
crisisèrent puis la deuxième question
est un petit peu en marche des questions
budgétaires mais comme Catherine ne l'a
pas évoqué je vais le ferai vous le
savez notre commission est très
attentive à la circulation des biens
culturels et à la préservation de
l'intégrité des collections nationales
avec Catherine de saillie et Pierre
Ouzoulias nous avons proposé à votre
prédécesseur un cadre permettant de
fonder cette politique qui est souvent
pris des tournures déplaisantes
vous le savez bien sûr le président de
la République a annoncé
lui-même une loi cadre et ceci depuis le
musée Jacques Chirac lors du départ du
Trésor d'abome vers le Bénin alors
question sont très simples où on somme
nous de la fabrique que de ce projet de
loi annoncé par le président de la
République
j'ai oublié aussi Lucien
oui madame la ministre c'est une
question sur la conservation du
patrimoine historique le depuis son
origine le dispositif Malraux vise à
contribuer à la conservation de ce petit
patrimoine dans les quartiers anciens
dégradé des villes c'est un outil très
précieux dans le cadre des politiques de
revêtualisation des centres bourg et des
centres-villes c'est un outil d'autant
plus précieux que votre ministère peut
contribuer à ce que la préservation du
patrimoine soit pris en compte dans les
dans les restaurations l'Inspection
Générale des Finances ainsi que les
salles des affaires de culturelles
avaient rendu en décembre 2018 un
rapport préconisant l'adaptation du
dispositif Malraux pour une meilleure
contribution et plus efficace à la
restauration des centres Bours et des
centres-villes de nombreuses
associations sauvegardes du patrimoine
on fait des propositions comme
l'augmentation du crédit d'impôt dans
lesquels pour les bâtiments dans
lesquels les loyers ne peuvent pas être
élevés ou encore une extension pour les
propriétaires occupants madame la
ministre ma question est la suivante les
discussions ont-elles été engagée au
niveau interministériel pour faire
évoluer ce dispositif et enfin quelle
est la position du ministère de la
Culture sur ce sujet merci
dernière question de Michel Los Angeles
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre
du coup c'est plutôt un plaidoyer que
que les questions parce que pas mal de
choses ont été vues déjà donc
néanmoins je souhaiterais que vous
puissiez revenir un petit peu sur la
question des de la hausse des coûts de
l'énergie et des fluides de savoir
exactement ce que vous allez
entreprendre par rapport à cette vague
qui arrive le deuxième point serait sur
le CNM alors sans anticiper le travail
que va faire notre collègue barjotant
comment vous pensez
faire en sorte que les majeurs cotisent
ce qui devraient cotiser ce qui n'est
pas semble-t-il le cas en ce moment
ensuite concernant la la crise la sortie
de la crise sanitaire
nombre important et ça a été évoqué par
notre collègue à propos du plan festival
non important de petits festivals et
moins festivals sont en train de fermer
parce qu'il n'arrive pas au nécessaire
pour se maintenir est-ce que vous avez
un plan dans ce cadre de plan festival
l'autre point c'est sur les les
opérateurs de spectacle qui qui se
produisent dans des locaux mis à
disposition par les collectivités
territoriales
l'effet de du coût de l'énergie et des
fluides va se répercuter sur les
collectivités et là quelle est la
position du ministère est-ce que il va y
avoir une aide au niveau des opérateurs
spectacles au niveau des collectivités
pour compenser pour éviter d'ailleurs
les fermetures de salles parce que c'est
ce qui pourrait arriver ensuite
ça touche aussi à recherche financières
bon il y a eu une évolution salutaire
des salaires et donc bien sûr la masse
salariale là aussi
additionner au surcoût de l'énergie des
fluides comment vous souhaitez
venir en aide au secteur et enfin
dernier point vous l'avez évoqué vous
même la question des JO de 2024 alors
même si c'est dans un an et demi
fait que aujourd'hui vous l'avez indiqué
une grande quantité de technicien
éclairagiste manutentionnaire service de
sécurité sont d'ores et déjà déjà
mobilisés pour les JO et pas uniquement
dans la région parisienne mais partout
en France et donc je voudrais savoir là
aussi pour l'ensemble des festivals et
en particulier des gros festivals
qu'est-ce que vous allez pouvoir mettre
au point comme dispositif et comme je
suis le régional de l'étape je plaide
pour celui bien sûr du Festival
d'Avignon
regroupant parce qu'il y a évidemment un
certain nombre de thèmes communs
énormément de questions sur le
patrimoine donc mon premier blog de
réponse va être là-dessus
je sens qu'il y a un certain nombre de
confusion par rapport à une vision qui
reste perçue par vous comme étant
centralisé de notre politique du
patrimoine alors que pas du tout là je
viens de vérifier des crédits qui sont
en DRAC hors plan de relance les crédits
monuments historiques donc tout ce que
le ministère fait pour protéger les
monuments historiques on a 9% en
Île-de-France 91% par tout ailleurs donc
vraiment je reprendrai le plan cathédral
4% en Île-de-France 96% hors
Île-de-France je pourrais vous donner
tous ces détails si vous ne me croyez
pas mais je vous assure que notre
politique du patrimoine elle est
totalement territoriale je rappelle
aussi l'existence de ce fond incitatif
pour le patrimoine que nous avons créé
avec les régions et qui permet de
soutenir davantage aussi avec les
collectivités le patrimoine on va dire
de proximité le patrimoine local sans
compter le loto du patrimoine qui permet
aussi d'aider ce qui n'est pas pas
protégé parce que vous le savez c'est en
fait
depuis la loi de 2004 qui a cette
séparation entre la responsabilité de
l'État sur le patrimoine protégé ainsi
classé et les autres qui ne le sont pas
notamment par exemple la majorité des
églises relèvent des collectivités ça
c'est un partage qui avait été fait dans
la loi évidemment au cas par cas on peut
y déroger on peut Via l’autodie
patrimoine soutenir aussi le patrimoine
des communes et le patrimoine des
propriétaires privés mais là si vous
voulez refonder complètement la
répartition entre l'État et les
collectivités sur le patrimoine ça va
être un énorme chantier parce que les
monuments historiques déjà c'est 40000
voir peut-être 50 000 je me trompe
peut-être de chiffres à cette heure
tardive c'est peut-être 55000 cela font
me corrige c'est entre les deux
[Rires]
c'est voilà
concernant les effectifs c'est vrai que
j'ai pas été très précise dans mes
réponses concernant les effectifs mais
on a dans le budget
2023 un certain nombre déjà de réponses
là les effectifs déconcentrés déjà dans
le domaine du patrimoine c'est quand
même 2400 équivalent temps plein c'est
pas rien c'est un énorme une énorme
moteur des agents du ministère
un effort là est fait pour réduire les
vacances de poste avec plusieurs
concours cette année pour les services
des drags on va avoir 101 précisément
nouveau agent technicien et ingénieur
qui vont pouvoir ces postes ventilés
entre les USAP en soutien aux
architectes des bâtiments de France et
dans les CRMH conservateurs régionaux
des monuments historiques et tout ça va
permettre de soutenir l'activité de
maîtrise d'ouvrage et d'assistance aux
propriétaires donc voilà une première
réponse sur les effectifs
concernant le patrim certaines religieux
bon je ne pourrais jamais être aussi
éloquente que le rapport que nous avons
mentionné
d'inventalon et de pierre ozoullias mais
juste vous redire aussi que
une grande partie en fait de ce que nous
soutenons en restauration monument
historique et dédiée au patrimoine
religieux c'est à peu près 100 millions
par an du budget des draps c'est une
grande partie de ce fond incitatif pour
le patrimoine que je mentionnais c'est
82 % des projets par exemple sur l'année
les années passées 576 projets entre
2018 et 2021 82 % porté sur le
patrimoine religieux c'est à peu près un
quart des projets j'ai regardé du Loto
du patrimoine sur le patrimoine
religieux je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous sur la nécessité de préserver
aussi de la même importance les
synagogues vous avez totalement raison
là-dessus d'ailleurs le loto du
patrimoine régulièrement permet de
soutenir toute la diversité du
patrimoine religieux je pense à la
synagogue de Verdun par exemple que j'ai
en tête
et pour les synagogues d'Alsace c'est un
sujet je pense assez spécifique sur
lequel nous devons nous pencher de
manière plus prioritaire il me semble
vous avez raison nous sommes en ce
moment en train de recruter un nouveau
une nouvelle drague grand est que cette
personne sera arrivée je pense que nous
devons faire une une campagne de
protection monument historique
spécifique pour protéger les synagogues
les plus emblématiques disons donc nous
vous associerons bien sûr assez ces
travaux
parmi vos différents sujets patrimoines
mais non pas totalement
vous avez mentionné le dispositif
Malraux merci de l'avoir évoqué alors
c'est quoi le dispositif Malraux c'est
une réduction d'impôts sur le revenu en
faveur des dépenses effectuées en vue de
la restauration complète d'un immeuble
bâti pour lequel une demande de permis
de construire ou une déclaration
préalable de travaux a été déposée
le taux de réduction d'impôts c'est de
22% et il peut être porté jusqu'à 30%
selon certaines conditions là dans le
PLF 2023 il n'y a pas de modification de
ce dispositif on a juste le souci de le
rendre plus plus efficient encore pour
pour notre patrimoine et plus lisible
mais merci de l'avoir évoqué
quant à Villers-Cotterêts chers sénateur
Brisson alors moi je suis quand même un
peu surprise on peut pas d'une part
nous demander de mieux soutenir le
patrimoine abandonné en déshérence dans
les collectivités or Île-de-France et
nous reprocher de sauver ce château
magnifique de François 1er qui était
mais dans un état désastreux abandonné
depuis des dizaines d'années
vous aviez des raisins et vous trouviez
surprenant qu'à l'heure de la sobriété
nous nous occupions de ce chantier
ah alors tant mieux tant mieux tant
mieux en tout cas le projet muséal
avance bien nous avons quatre
commissaires de grands talents qui
travaillent sur le parcours permanent de
visite Barbara Cassin l'académicienne
Xavier northe qui est dirigeait le
département de la langue française au
ministère de la Culture Zef gourarier
qui dirigeait les collections du Mucem
et Hassan Kouyaté qui dirige le festival
des francophonies de Limoges donc on a
ce quatuor qui pense le parcours de
cette partie disons muséale mais en fait
le château de Villers-Cotterêts n'est
pas un musée ça va être une cité c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle comme tel ça
être un lieu vivant un lieu aussi de
résidence avec une douzaine d'ateliers
de studios de résidence il va y avoir un
auditorium il y aura des concerts des
films enfin ça va être un lieu vivant
dans toutes les disciplines avec aussi
des activités associatives éducatives
qui vont pouvoir s'y déployer en tout
cas c'est un projet qui qui n'a rien
d'ordres qui est construit avec aussi un
grand les autres partenaires de la
Francophonie un grand réseau
d'associations au niveau local les les
établissements scolaires et à chaque
journée du patrimoine j'ai l'occasion de
voir à quel point ça crée un engouement
au niveau local et une maison du
chantier aussi qui permet tout au long
du chantier de faire vivre ce chantier
auprès de la population il y a eu un
camion de langues de France qui s'est
déplacé aussi en haute France bref
énormément de choses je pourrais vous
passer tous ces détails et surtout je
serai ravi d'inviter la Commission à une
visite du chantier avant l'ouverture si
ça vous intéresse parce que je sens
qu'il y a besoin d'y aller ensemble et
de voir sur place je suis sûr que vous
serez convaincu
concernant
l'éducation artistique l'enseignement
artistique et tous les enjeux que nous
partageons pour la jeunesse
finalement toutes ces interventions
montrent à quel point vous avez raison
je l'ai peut-être pas assez dit dans mon
propos introductifs il est important que
les jeunes pratiquent l'art et la
culture c'est pas uniquement de faire
deux des consommateurs entre guillemets
qui vont acheter des billets pour aller
à des spectacles ou à des musées mais
faire deux des protagonistes faire deux
des acteurs de la vie culturelle et leur
permettre eux-mêmes de
s'essayer à la musique à l'art à
la danse au théâtre voir d'en faire leur
métier si le souhaitent plus tard mais
en tout cas de leur donner cette
initiation à la pratique artistique
c'est ce que permet aujourd'hui de plus
en plus le Pass Culture parce qu'on a
voulu transformer encore plus le Pass
Culture en passe de pratique où ils
peuvent acheter des instruments de
musique prendre des cours cette
dimension aussi sera très importante
dans le passe objectifs au collège et au
lycée pour que les enseignants puissent
non seulement faire des sorties
scolaires mais aussi emmener invité des
auteurs en résidence des musiciens enfin
en tout cas permettre aussi la pratique
en classe de manière plus libre
peut-être que ce qu'on peut avoir dans
certains cours de musique ou d'arts
plastiques mais en tout cas c'est un
vrai sujet concernant les les
établissements d'enseignement en fait il
y en a deux sortes il y a les les
conservatoires qui dépendent de l'état
les conservatoires rayonnements régional
en tout cas qui sont financés par l'État
il y a tous ceux qui relèvent des
collectivités là encore vous le savez
faire madame Morin de saillie vous
connaissez bien ces sujets aujourd'hui
on a en fait 1500 structures au total
d'enseignements artistiques spécialisés
c'est assez gigantesque comme réseau en
France c'est très belle nouvelle
d'ailleurs pour notre pays mais il y a
une répartition aussi là assez subtile
moi-même j'ai travaillé en collectivité
auprès de Bertrand Delanoë qui était
très attaché à l'enjeu du développement
des conservatoires notamment donc je
connais bien le sujet mais là encore
l'état peut pas totalement se substituer
au collectivité pour ce qui est des
conservateurs des conservatoires
municipaux pour ce qui est de la musique
mais évidemment il y a tous les sujets
de la prise en compte de du
développement des autres établissements
qui sont eux classés par l'État il y en
a à peu près 382 moi en tout cas j'avais
insisté dans la présentation du budget
sur les établissements supérieurs
d'enseignement artistique puisque là
nous avons une priorité budgétaire pour
venir en aide aux étudiants les plus en
difficulté avec plus de bourse soutenir
plus particulièrement les écoles
d'architecture sur lesquels je mets un
enjeu particulier merci aussi de les
avoir cités comme étant ses laboratoires
de la transition écologique de demain
puisqu'on a là 20 000 étudiants qui vont
être les bâtisseurs les constructeurs de
demain et donc forcément d'une autre
manière de construire et de bâtir qui
sera plus éco-responsable
j'insiste aussi sur la lecture il y a
des actions qui coûtent de l'argent
comme soutenir une manifestation
littéraire des résidences d'auteurs dans
les écoles que le Centre national du
livre va déployer dans la continuité de
la lecture grande cause nationale mais
il y a aussi des actions qui ne coûtent
pas très cher en budget mais qui coûte
en mobilisation en énergie et encore des
nations par exemple le quart d'heure de
lecture auquel je tiens beaucoup j'en
reparle régulièrement avec mon collègue
Pape Ndiaye on le voit dans les régions
les départements où s'est mis en place
par exemple en Bretagne où ça se passe
très bien mais pas que quand les élèves
s'arrêtent 15 minutes pour lire pour le
plaisir que ce soit un livre un magazine
une BD c'est une énorme différence au
bout de quelques mois dans une classe en
termes de concentration d'amélioration
du vocabulaire des relations entre les
élèves et cet impact là il a pas de prix
je tiens un jour on arrive vraiment à ce
que toute la France tous les jours
s'arrête 15 minutes pour lire on aura
gagné
on peut rêver mais ça me semble
atteignable parce qu'en plus voilà tout
le monde a des livres dans ses
bibliothèques CCDI on peut déployer plus
de livres aussi si ça manque la lecture
à voix haute aussi on la développe
j'insiste aussi sur ce point concernant
les aides à la presse je vous rejoins
monsieur Assouline je pense qu'on a un
gros chantier devant nous de réforme des
aides à la presse du ministère nous nous
y attend
je suis aussi impatiente des États
généraux du droit à l'information pour
entendre toutes les recommandations
préconisations qui sortiront à ce
moment-là j'ai déjà commencé à me
plonger dans le détail des aides à la
presse des aides aux radios aussi et je
pense qu'on a là une modernisation et un
ajustement et une réforme de fond
je suis d'accord avec votre diagnostic
des États généraux vont commencer début
décembre et se déployer jusqu'au mois
d'avril mai nous pourrons vous en dire
plus bientôt
concernant le Centre national de la
musique
nous attendons le démarrage mais ça y
est il est presque lancé notre la
mission du sénateur Julien barjoton qui
va permettre un peu de faire le point
sur tous les enjeux de financement de la
filière musicale et quelles sont les
différentes hypothèses qu'elles sont les
positions des uns et des autres tous les
acteurs de la filière ne sont pas tous
d'accord et pour ouvrir sur le metaves
les NFT et tous ces mondes numériques
avec leurs opportunités et leur menaces
je vous signale juste je vais pas vous
le développer là mais je vous invite à
aller le lire on l'a présenté hier nous
a été remis à Jean-Noël Barrault et
moi-même un rapport sur le métaver par
trois experts Camille François Adrien
Batman et Rémy Ronfard c'est passionnant
et tente vraiment de définir et
d'embrasser tous les enjeux liés à ces
mondes métaversie comme ils disent
ça nous fera de bonnes discussions à
venir pour nos prochains échanges
merci beaucoup et merci de votre
engagement pour la culture merci Madame
la Ministre alors vous avez terminé
votre propos liminaire par des verres de
Garcia Lorca je terminerai cette réunion
par une citation de niche je connais ma
destinée un jour s'attachera à mon nom
quelque chose de formidable je ne sais
pas si nous utiliserons ce qualificatif
de formidable à l'issue du débat sur le
PLF mais en tout cas je ne doute pas que
si vous reprenez à votre compte les
amendements du Sénat se rapprochera
merci Madame la Ministre merci pour la
poésie la littérature Nietzsche gramsky